[Musique]
vous tombez sur une image une photo qui
vous sommes invraisemblables une
histoire peut être loufoque trop belle
ou rocambolesques pour être vrai alors
voici quelques trucs pour en vérifier
l'authenticité
prenons l'exemple de cette photo du
gouverneur républicain de la floride ron
de santé ce qui a circulé récemment il
tient sur cette image un t-shirt sur
lequel on lit en anglais il y a quatre
choses inutiles dans ce monde un libéral
wack le vaccin cours de la coved le
masque et justin trudeau alors est ce
que cette image est véridique vous
pouvez tout d'abord effectuer une
recherche inversée sur internet google
est très utile pour cela il existe aussi
d'autres sites comparables comme tenai
par exemple ou encore l'équivalent russe
de google qui s'appelle yandex au
décrypteront l'utilisent beaucoup son
algorithme est très puissant vous verrez
les résultats vous aurez besoin de
télécharger l'image en question sur
votre appareil mobile ou votre
ordinateur ou encore utiliser l'adresse
web de cette image ce qu'on appelle
l'url ensuite rendez vous sur par
exemple google imoges google images et
faites une recherche par image versez
votre image ou encore copier son url
dans le champ de recherche google vous
donnera ensuite tous les résultats tous
les sites internet ou des versions de
cette image là apparaissent ensuite
comparé les résultats de votre recherche
avec l'histoire initiale et posez vous
la question est-ce que ça concorde en
tout point ici d'un cas qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui on voit que non la photo
originale date en fait de septembre 2019
donc bien avant la pandémie rentrer de
santé stone et un t-shirt promotionnelle
d'un restaurant de poulets frits de
miami une photo qu'il a tweeté à ses
abonnés le verdict la photo qui parle de
justin trudeau est une supercherie c'est
faut absolument faux
[Musique]